parmi les films en français projetés au
tiff plusieurs le sont en premières
mondiales
dont vikings du réalisateur québécois
stéphane lafleur et la gravité du franco
burkinabè cédric ido l'histoire d'un
quartier de banlieue dont l' équilibre
sera bousculée par un événement cosmique
justement josé pas espérer que le
prennent pas ce que c'était pour moi
c'était vraiment le festival
c'est un festival où les gens viennent
vraiment voir les films le français
christian carion lui est venu présenter
son film une belle course qu'il met en
scène les acteurs dany boon et line
renaud traversant les rues de paris en
taxis avenue dechavanne à courbevoie
traverser tout cas où le to grow cette
première projection devant un public
nord américain principalement anglophone
en quoi c'est un peu le réalisateur mais
il se réjouit d'avoir cette tribune
la culture c'est la langue
donc
que que des films circulent dans leur
langue maternelle c'est très important
les films de france sont ainsi nombreux
à s'être taillé une place dans la
programmation du tiff cette année on
compte près d'une cinquantaine de
productions ou coproductions française
selon l'organisme de promotion unis
france par rapport au nombre de films
dans leur totalité à toronto c'est un
record donc on est extrêmement bien
représentée et les artistes se sont
beaucoup déplacé dans vienne 1 nombreux
pour être là présents avec leur film
parce que c'est vraiment important parmi
les quelques productions canadiennes en
français il ya le film rosie un projet à
part puisqu'il s'agit en réalité d'un
film bilingue il raconte l'histoire
d'une orpheline autochtone forcés
d'aller vivre avec sa tante francophone
qu'elle ne connaît pas jouée par mélanie
bray c'est mieux que ce soit avec vous
vous êtes l'apparenté
l'actrice montréalaise regrette qu'on ne
voit pas justement plus de ses films
bilingue au canada c'est bizarre parce
qu'on est tous dans le même pays mais on
vit vraiment dans le monde différent on
dirait les anglophones et les
francophones ont souvent mais les
festivals comme celui ci dit elles
servent aussi à inspirer ce genre de
projet ici qu'à me grégoire radio canada
toronto